great stuff so we've just gone through
an outlaw in the day so it sounds like
what's happened so far we've outline
what we're looking for in an HMO now
we've got a three or four or even five
properties never wind up which we're
going to go out and check out and we're
going to go and see if how they probably
move a lot so here we are in Stafford
we've just come from a 4-bedroom
property and it's on for less than
100,000 four-bedroom exactly what we're
looking for so we're just going to go in
have a look and we'll be back with a
report but if we're actually able to get
five bedrooms yeah so the rents going to
be quite high however we're going to
really lift this it's not really bad
condition but why they choose green
carpets I really don't know so we're
gonna need to spend a few grand on this
getting up to speed but we don't like
doing work so it's a little bit of a
pull off that we can have to change the
carpets and the kitchens a bit iffy but
there we go yeah anyway more to say so
that's the day right near the centre of
Wolverhampton just off the main road no
stops outside and we're gonna have to
look round and see what we can do
we've got a really big sunroom which
would be quite a good communal area boy
it's one wall in here maximising as well
and we've got here a a bathroom but
while I'm thinking potentially to do
will be to knock this wall out here put
a door here and just have this and wall
of good-sized bedroom it's a pistol
bullets a so we've got a bedroom here
possibly kitchen which is quite nice
what happen with the kitchen communal
area here and Danny what you could
possibly do would be to put a corridor
here and then to run along here and to
turn this into a bedroom as well another
option for a bedroom which is currently
not being used as a bedroom so and then
you've got a third reception room here
potentially this is obviously even via
Metro so that could be in the area could
be a bedroom this is definitely unit
bedroom again it's double glazed front
of the house big window you can see
we're on the the main road here with
buses going faster to me every few
minutes so that's the downstairs
if you remember downstairs there was a
big bathroom that we said we could turn
into a bedroom problem that would be
that would leave us only this bathroom
for five people and we if you don't want
five people share the bathroom so the
thing to do potentially would be to put
a sink here and then to have an ensuite
yeah for the back row next door so then
you've got five bedrooms four people
share one bathroom bedroom suite and
five rooms two bathrooms yeah I think
about 1750 went very well the space of
it we could do some things again nice
big hallway which is a good-size double
room again dog lanes nice condition
we've got a bedroom as well upstairs
with it being over three floors and
having at least five people in there you
wouldn't need a license the asking price
for the house is just one hundred and
fifteen thousand pounds it seems like
it's in really good condition it's not
going to take much work to get us off
the grounds lady seems really really
great stuff high five
fantastic so we decided in the end not
to go for a five bed then then Simon
what were your reasoning behind that I
think the properties where you either
tap with the four bedrooms
needed that's worth doing to them so it
was going to be a lot less hassle to get
the HMO up and running and getting
tenants in there as soon as possible
you didn't particularly want to get a
license no I mean although it's only a
small amount over five years I think
just the hassle you hasn't really worth
it so we did we decided on there
and slightly more expensive mortgage
possibility than potentially having to
be a bit more strict on them on the fire
alarms getting more high quality fire
alarms so we've gone for a four-bed
property in a fantastic location isn't
it really really bang on just off the I
just don't basically Birmingham Road and
what are those sort of figures Simon so
well at the moment we've offered 95 500
and we're hoping except that it was on
to 120 it was on for what well I mean
I've read that you don't need to spend
upwards of a hundred thousand pounds to
get a fantastic investment property it's
definitely a stone saying pays to know
people in the industry and establish
some good relationships with the local
estate agents incredibly important
otherwise you're going to miss you're
guaranteed that the estate agent is is
calling the people who've gotten a
special list to get property stuff yeah
or even get something cuz your
experience you actually you were looking
on right before we're now yeah and
hanging you have a brick wall tell us
about your experience of that and what
happened and I think the the properties
that make it onto right move are perhaps
just a little bit more expensive than
you would ideally be looking at as an
investor so straight off the bat you'd
be spending more money than you are yeah
and also you just you're not gain the
properties that are going to make an
idea how to mow are going to be dished
out before it goes on so the one that
you've bought really good location
you've got four room three really big
rooms and then one decent-sized room
yeah 1,400 rent were you gonna buy it
for less than 100 and is in really nice
condition isn't it not much left to be
done to it at all
absolutely incredible really I can
believe I've walked away having poor
house through this crossed as long as
nothing here I think goes awry and it's
been a valuable lesson for me sounds to
me a lot of things and certainly boosted
my confidence with looking at property
in the future so I hope thank you very
much
cool how's your job going
oh yeah no traffic you're right I'm just
just very cool about 10 minutes after
you left I had a phone call from David
the estate agents okay
that's been tuning and growing it
decided that they will accept our offer
was not as high as 500 back so a
fantastic
buy more houses in real life like this
and don't forget to like share and
subscribe and the more you do that the
more we will film if you're also
interested in investing yourself and
getting crazy high returns then don't
forget go down to www.hyken.com at UK
and we can help you do that too